le tronçon ouest de la nécrose verront
le jour il viendra et servir des
secteurs viandier des besoins
principalement dans le grand sud ouest
de l'est de montréal
effectivement transport collectif peut
rassembler au lieu de diviser donc nos
élus ont travaillé dans votre monde se
parle tout le monde dit la même chose
c'est extraordinaire etc sauf bien sûr
je pense que ça paraît je suis très fier
valerie plame madame la mairesse bonsoir
bonsoir
visiblement aujourd'hui c'était
difficile de contenir votre joie votre
pierre péan la vue ça tournait en boucle
dans les réseaux d'information qu'est ce
qui vous réjouit le plus dans ce
dénouement bain et je voudrais que deux
choses la première c'est d'avoir réussi
à trouver une entente qui était bonne et
pour québec et pour montréal ça c'est
certain parce que un projet comme celui
du tramway à québec je l' ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises c'est nécessaire
c'est une excellente idée
et évidemment le deuxième aspect de mon
enthousiasme
c'est évidemment le financement de ce
projet le tronçon ouest est allé grohl
un projet auquel je suis très attaché
c'était au coeur de votre projet
politique on le sait très bien
d'ailleurs présenté un graphique pour
que nos téléspectateurs puissent
comprendre quel est ce tronçon ouest qui
était dans ce projet original de la
ligne rose entre l'arrondissement
ville-marie c'est à dire le centre-ville
et la chine donc c'est ça dont on parle
aujourd'hui exit pour le moment l'autre
tronçon le tronçon principal qui donc
cette voie de métro vers le nord de
l'île toutefois ce qu'on voit ici à
l'écran là ça va être lié à ce qui sera
le projet de tramway vers l'est de la
ville est un peu seul plan d'ensemble
mais jusqu'à quel point ça veut
désengorger la ligne orange c'est ça
votre objectif depuis le début se passer
là oui absolument et puis quand je me
suis assise avec
ministre dubé je lui ai dit écoutez
monsieur le ministre on a déjà un projet
de tramway dans l'est alors pourquoi est
ce qu'on ne le continue pas jusque dans
l'ouest
et ça serait tellement un projet
fédérateur justement est et ouest
ensemble et puis nous on avait déjà fait
un début de travail pour voir comment
est ce que le tronçon oued un gros
c'était possible d'ailleurs on avait
toujours en campagne que c'était un
tronçon qui était en surface étant donné
l'existence de réseaux ferroviaires
aussi intéressant dans l'ouest alors moi
la suggestion que j'ai fait ou aux
présentes conseil du trésor va il le
saisit jans très heureuse mais il est où
l'autre bout également celui qui est
sous terre qui est un métro de montréal
nord au centre vicieux vous irez france
rimonabant nantes est ce que vous y
renoncer à la notation bull est la
version entière pleine et entière de ce
projet de la ligne rose
non non pas du tout parce que j'y vais
par étapes
alors j'ai décidé après j'ai réussi à
faire financer des études pour évaluer
l'impact de l'achalandage sur la ligne
orange et ça inclut le tronçon est de la
lune à orange mais également la station
berri-uqam et dans à peu près un an
devrait déjà avoir des données et même
des propositions de commandes est
engorgé et moi je suis assez en a je
suis assez enthousiaste ou du moins je
pense que les données vont nous donner
raison
ceci étant dit si ça devait être une
autre technologie que métro si ça devait
être une autre couleur je les dis moi je
suis pas dogmatique
ce que je veux c'est des solutions et
puis je content que le gouvernement soit
au rendez vous qu'il ait la même
approche et d'avoir décidé ok on va
jusque dans l'ouest avec notre amour
parce que c'est une bonne idée justement
monsieur bonnardel aujourd'hui dans les
corridors de l'assemblée nationale
madame plantes il refusait de parler de
ligne rose non il n'est pas question
c'est pas de son d'anti question donc
joué en ouverture le dans votre attitude
désir on peut appeler ça autrement mais
parlons de vos relations avec québec
ce qu'on a vu récemment au cours des
derniers mois des dernières semaines
entre certains l'ont interprété comme ça
c'est une tension qui s'est installée là
des désaccords deux dossiers en
particulier que je vais évoquer avec
vous la question du cannabis la laïcité
il ya eu des frictions avec québec est
ce qu'on est en droit de dire bailleur
réconciliation à l'horizon avec son ski
tard aujourd'hui
mais s'apprête à bégoux
- étaient peu de temps s était pas parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur certains
projets qu'il ya des frictions et moi je
travaille extrêmement bien avec
l'ensemble des ministres parce qu'il ya
le travail il ya les prestations là il
ya comment on parle aux médias mais
derrière après ça une fois que la caméra
est peut-être un travail qui se fait
bien évidemment
alors pour le cannabis moi je suis
satisfait de l'ouverture et je dirais du
compromis qui était fait de la part du
gouvernement du québec pour s'adapter à
la réalité montréalaise
et pour ce qui est la laïcité bien que
je ne suis pas d'accord avec le projet
de loi en tant que tel et je suis très
préoccupé pour son application
j'ai dit que j'allais respecter la
volonté du gouvernement du québec
ce que je m'emploie faire revenons
maintenant à la question de ce tronçon
ouest de la ligne rose à quel moment
madame plantes vous espérez a coupé le
ruban monter à bord de ce tramway la
proverbiale pelletée de terre
vous allez me dire vous avez pas de date
précise mais mais quand même le
représentant leur thème parler de 18
mois pour produire les études mais
ensuite
est-ce que vous avez un choix à tout le
moins dans cinq ans dans quatre rendez
vous au chili c'est pour moi de vous
donner cette date l'ozone deal et du
fauchage
- pourquoi une idée parce que les gens
veulent savoir dans sud ouest la ville
ils veulent il veut savoir ça va se
faire mais j'avais envie pour dire qu'il
faut falloir qu'on pose la question
entre autres au ministre dubé
mais madame rouleau et la ministre ou
l'eau parce que moi ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai mis de l'avant quand j'ai parlé du
tronçon wasa les grosses de dire vous
on sait quel point le gouvernement de
l'acca qui est attaché au tramway de
l'est
et lorsque je souhaite c'est que quand
on va faire le tramway de l'est tout de
suite on continue jusqu'à la chine pour
faire justement ce grand axe est ouest
alors à quel moment je sais pas
aujourd'hui je pense que je vais m'en
remettre à la victoire à la célébration
parce qu'au final c'est tellement une
belle nouvelle pour les montréalais
montréalaise mépris pour le québec qui
veut du premier projet de transport
collectif
d'où le choix du rose que vous portez
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs monsieur dubé ou
si portel heureusement profitons-en pour
pâques baseball aussi madame plantes en
terminant monsieur bronfman est sorti
publiquement aujourd'hui pour parler de
ses pleins ça vous dit quoi vous cette
gare de partager entre tampa bay
montréal comment la ville de montréal
plus arrimé à ce projet là ben écoute et
on voit qu'il ya vraiment des des étapes
ans qui s'affranchissent de deux mois
des discussions sérieuses et pour ce qui
est du partage d'une équipe
moi je vais vraiment laissé aux
promoteurs parce que je me rappelle la
ville de montréal n'est pas promoteur du
projet du retour du baseball
moi j'ai dit qu'on allait on le voit ces
envoyés sur d'un bon oeil et qu'on
allait répondre présent si on pouvait
soutenir d'une façon ou d'une autre le
retour d'une équipe alors à ce moment
aussi
moi je vais laisser les étapes continuer
je vois ça d'un bon oeil
évidemment mais pour ce qui est du
montage financier de la pertinence de ce
conseil qui vaut bien voilà pour le
terrain
le stade nécessairement je vais laisser
monsieur brafman répondre à ces
questions là surtout qu'avec monsieur
boivin ça a été dit clairement des
débuts assez content du kavé de montréal
n'allait pas mettre de l'argent
directement dans un stade de baseball
c'est ça fait pas partie de nos
priorités surtout qui est tellement de
choses qu'on doit on doit prioriser à la
ville de montréal dont le transport
collectif la mobilité merci beaucoup
valérie plein merci